hello and welcome to this video where a
bit untimely start and even the Blitz
number is wrong so oops I just did that
so pre move is my opponent pre moved
like pretty moves okay so let's go for
the watchful Knights mm-hmm ready you
got a decision here you know maybe it
was just looking for the coffee
yeah bishop before now is there
overwhelming mainline that is also a
possible move I think white is a bit
better but it's nothing nothing terrible
of course want you to try to take in
premium for that just for for just the
case it takes such whites intention is
to play Queen d2 long castles and this
is extremely comfortable for white I'm a
lot I'm ahead quite a lot in development
and I have the immediate five threat you
know
yeah just e5 next I could have played it
immediately but mmm I wasn't sure I felt
like I maybe even get more yeah but you
know d5 takes
yeah maybe maybe I don't get more and I
should have done something simpler
yeah in any case it is a rather
comfortable position okay this is maybe
a bit dicey but you need to grabbing
that takes a bit of yeah need to be
brave to take the chief whap on I think
black probably should do it if you just
allows g5 next move that looks really
awful
he takes a really long time
he and already stages of the game
hmm Wow
there was a baton
one real upside of X game is it is
extremely simple you just push the
Hawking side and then see how black is
going to defend against it it's not
going to be a hole that easy
okay so maybe g5 was actually a little
bit and not not well-timed and you can
check on c4
yeah probably
this is good huh he takes g5 I take g7
Queen takes rook h7 King f7 rook h1
check and that wins I didn't take that
into account at all I don't think it
works okay let's take the Queen cannot
take as then the knight is going to be
taken and now
mm okay probably recouped g1 looks
strong yeah let's just do it and now it
is six that should win rook h7s I don't
there's no way to prevent it really and
there's g7 check as well oh wow okay and
mate next this is made okay yeah that
was I think a good warning this game
against this way of playing Bishop c5 is
fine but you should go but should be 60m
this white is threatening Knight X is
six so then you have to react in some
way I'm sorry yeah this is the way it is
normally played castles castles long
piayed and this is some yeah that leads
to an interesting game so a black took
everything and now I just have a
dominant position in the center with the
Queen Bishop g7 probably e5 is strong I
mean I saw that but I saw that I will
probably win this pawn but I felt I can
maybe do better you know what I did not
see is that you cannot even castle
because of they should be 5-1 95 95 this
may be stronger even but this is also
looking very strong
I didn't didn't take that into account
but okay I have a huge central advantage
it doesn't relieve it's clearly better
anyway so G for now okay that's even
stronger don't you need to sacrifice a
pawn and this is a dicey move and black
should probably take it I would have
played rubgy one and I overlooked Queen
to f6 that is a really strong defense
and that refutes this idea completely
okay so Luke g1 is not good and if that
is not good then g4s not good so G for
wasn't mistaken we should have taken
that and I mean even even if it wasn't
for Queen f6 you should take it just out
of principle you're in suffering and you
should just get a pawn and here I just
have this automatic attack for for
nothing basically and age six is killing
him yeah it's totally devastating the
kid at the point is that this is leading
to a mate already I'm sorry I'm sorry
it's not I made this Queen age six I
mean this is this is basically made okay
yes can do that but that's what I saw
and and this is possible but you're not
surviving this of course the King is
completely out in the open but it's
maybe not a force made like this and
yeah black black gets killed here with
the king
yeah ninety form look D to G oneness
what I play it and it's fit should win
yeah yeah it's it's is really too much
six here we have the image coming up
yeah that whole variation is really to
be avoided like those traits on before
they are really good from black point of
view because the Queen is fantastic in
the center it's doing all kinds of
things in and this kid it's not going to
be attacked anymore because the lights
the minor pieces that cannot take it to
already trade it off okay guys thanks
for watching